[Musique]
allez le sport à présent avec vous
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir mon sens
car elle nous présentait bien sûr comme
tous les lundis les résultats sportifs
dans le département du vtt pour
commencer cette chronique
c'est une véritable tradition dans les
yvelines ce dimanche 23 juin à 9h30
précises 160 coureurs se sont réunis au
pied de la colline d'elancourt pour
participer à la 21e édition de la
revancharde une course de vtt qui s'est
tenue sous les températures estivales
cette année un tracé de 5,9 km a été
imaginé par les organisateurs sur le
futur site olympique et des compétitions
de vtt en 2024 on écoute l'un des
organisateurs niveau difficulté assez
élevé comme voilà après fo fo est assez
technique par endroit il ya un peu de
roullens faut savoir faire du vtt pendre
je sais que voilà là où il s'aventure
avec leurs vélos moi je descendrai je
descendrai côté c'est sûr il a bien
boucler ses cinq tours nicolas 10 mai de
gif-sur-yvette remporte cette édition on
écoute sa réaction eu beau parmentier
qui est parti devant cave et 20 à 30
secondes d'avancé suite avec cédric
chartier on est revenus tous les deux
petit à petit et voilà ensuite on a fait
le petit groupe de trois et ensuite ben
on s'est attaqué juste dans la fin la
dernière bosse en parallèle l'événement
a permis de récolter près de 2 2500
euros en faveur des orphelins des
sapeurs pompiers
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition du football a présenté
quelle direction le club de football de
trappes l'annoncé tombée ce week-end en
assemblée général mustapha larbaoui a
décidé de quitter la structure après 16
années passées au club dont 14 à sa
présidence potentiel tête de liste à la
mairie de la commune il ne voudrait pas
mélanger les genres en écoute justement
la réaction de mustapha larbaoui
associatif avec la politique
au javelot d'éducateurs dans la campagne
et pourra durant les campagnes de rester
en dehors du champ politique pour
l'association est préservée sur
l'association au delà de la sphère
politique
donc nous l'appliquer moi même tout
simplement pendant des années un projet
à la pause
mais rassurez-vous grégory mustapha
larbaoui a déjà annoncé qu'il viendrait
supporter ses désormais ex joueur sur le
terrain abderrezak guessoum reste
président du club
on termine par un hommage c'était à
magny les hameaux pour la sixième année
consécutive un tournoi amical en hommage
à l'ancien capitaine du club franck
klimko s'est déroulée samedi au stade de
jacques anquetil au rendez vous a réuni
dix équipes venues de l'île de france
dont les clubs de jouy en josas et
montigny le bretonneux présent depuis
les débuts on écoute les réactions au
micro d'aurélie ans ça nous a pris un
peu de temps pour organiser le tournoi
mais ça fait on a mis quatre ans à peu
près avoir cette idée et du coup là ça
fait six ans qu'on pérennise le tournoi
et je pense que vu le monde qu'il ya
aujourd'hui et vu comment ça fonctionne
chaque année ça a l'air de ça à l'air de
bien marcher du coup déjà c'est pour
rendre un hommage je rende hommage à la
personne qu'on connaissait à franck inco
et et revoir des amis qu'on voit pas
tout le temps est passé une superbe
journée ensoleillée en plus après la
journée de compétition c'est finalement
fontenay le fleury qui remporte le
tournoi pour sa première participation
merci à mikel pour ce tour d'horizon
plus d'actualité sportive bien sûr à
venir après ce journal votre émission le
cetud sport comme tous les lundis sur tv